[Music]
huh he's a bucket
uh get back in the car and drive time is
running out
man you ever been on the course like
this nope you've got some new volkswagen
rtm
so what you think of it man i think it's
dope it's real sporty got a nice little
model to it so i can't wait to test it
out and let's go man i hope you can
drive man you got your license yeah
i'm safe yeah let's go let's go there
man let's whip man
had to make sure you had your license
first bro i want you just driving
cause i didn't have my lights until i
turned 21 bro oh yeah facts bro i don't
know i was just so used to catching the
bus i was like
cool with it i guess but tell me a
little bit about just being from north
carolina but what like what was it like
growing up as a kid out there
um it was slow moving it wasn't too much
to get into bahoot that's all that's all
you could do
i started playing since i was little my
older brother played it so i was always
around it i always played travel
basketball and then once i hit the high
school that's kind of where i took off
at
i remember you in high school but when i
came watching but i was like man who's
this kid with all his hair hitting
fadeaways
and dunking on people yeah so yeah we
got it up here like now we got a little
faster little 40 miles per hour bro feel
good
yeah yeah we got it got out there quick
like i can only imagine
just smashing through on this track
right now yeah
like how does it feel you know handling
she's smooth smooth
got a nice little rod to it the
interior's nice of course yeah
don't you love the new whip smell like
yeah
smell good in here yeah
we're at the start line man and we got
this obstacle course so
first you got to zigzag through the raw
cones till you get to the rack of
basketballs
then you get out and you shoot all the
balls in the trunk
once you're done you got to drive
through a royal cones parked by another
rack of balls and shoot those in the
trunk
there's a little kicker if you knock
over cones it's two seconds off your
time
you beat the 90 seconds you get to take
a victory lap
if not i'm doing the victory lap and i'm
gonna leave you out here in the cold
we got this let's get it
give you the three two one and you just
take off and we go
you ready yep all right ready three
two one go here we go
[Music]
yup just stop in the stop box perfect
now go
this one called four oh one uh
ah that's good huh
these are buckets huh let's go close
truck close the truck
close the see chuck
safety first man clicking her ticket
[Music]
um
126. what's what he said let's go
hey and that shows real jump shots man
real jump shots work
what was the most difficult part about
the obstacle course after you get the
second basketball it's all the best
balls in there right you're shooting
them it's hitting those coming out yeah
the ball is coming out bashing out but
trunk was real spacey so that made it
easy uh
you know just going around the cones
that made it easy because of the car so
since i made the time
i get to do my victory lap oh man enjoy
that victory you're live
don't leave me bro it's freezing out
[Music]
here
[Music]
you